muamar al gadafi el excéntrico autócrata
que gobernó libia durante 42 años murió
hace una década en 1969 él lideró el
golpe de estado militar que derrocó al
rey idrís al-senussi instauró un consejo
de la revolución con el que hizo grandes
cambios en el país entre la década de
1990 y los años 2000 con el abandono del
desarrollo de armas de destrucción
masiva libia salió de la categoría
estado paria a la de miembro pleno de la
comunidad internacional hábil
revolucionario idealista pero también
imprevisible temido y déspota al gadafi
y reprimió duramente algunas
manifestaciones de sus opositores en
febrero de 2011 la violenta represión
contra la disidencia provocó una guerra
civil en cuestión de meses los
opositores lograron dominar gran parte
del territorio libio con la toma de
trípoli en agosto de 2011 al gadafi cuyó
a la ciudad de sirte desde donde gobernó
paralelamente al instalado consejo
nacional de transición con el
advenimiento de la primavera árabe que
derrocó a los gobernantes de túnez y
egipto a principios de 2011 se inició
una revuelta popular en libia contra el
gadafi cercado por sus oponentes trató
de huir por una alcantarilla pero lo
atraparon y mataron de inmediato para
muchos su muerte significó el fin de la
tiranía y la dictadura sin embargo el
poder estatal se vino abajo y se
formaron dos gobiernos en enero de este
año se acordó que abdul hamid baby sería
el primer ministro interino quien debe
preparar las elecciones presidenciales y
parlamentarias de diciembre que por lo
pronto se han pospuesto un mes diez años
después de la desaparición de al gadafi
los libios siguen lidiando con la
inestabilidad la proliferación de armas
una economía que se hunde y una tasa de
desempleo del 19 por ciento